so when the android framework goes to
start your application from launcher
icon or an app shortcut or what you see
when you're doing multi window those are
all activities right so they really are
kind of the entry point into your apps
UI right when the user goes to launch
your app they're launching an activity
what you actually want is you want to
build the layering you actually need so
in this case we can have multiple things
multiple destinations within an activity
right and share information across each
of these destinations by using the
activity scope as an actual useful
element now so for example you could
have a shared view element or view model
that both destinations talk to so one
destination could put data in and the
other one could observe changes to that
data right you don't need to work at the
application scope level for this to work
what we're thinking about this like if
we're moving from this activity world to
a destination role we really want to
make that world as easy as possible
right otherwise why it would be moved
and we focused on kind of two things one
was the global UI kind of thing like how
can we make that part easy right like
it's something that every app kind of
has the same kind of patterns and we
really don't want that to be something
that takes a lot of effort to do
also the navigating between destinations
right that start activity activity
compat thing can we make that even
easier so we started the navigation
architecture component and we introduced
it to you all in IO this last year in
if you have arguments to something how
do we make this nice so we built a
cradle plugin called safeguards which
for every destination in your graph such
as this main fragment we generate a
directions object which has a nice
simple show profile method which gives
you a directions object with typesafe
arguments that you define in your
navigation graph and then you just call
a navigate and that's it will take care
of all of the fragment transaction and
all of that sort of stuff for you so
this makes a lot easier so rule number
one of testing things at the destination
level is don't test the destination
level it's really the number one thing
with testing right is making things nice
and separate and extracting some of that
business logic out of a destination and
into something you can test in isolation
so how can we do this
so last this Monday we released fragment
1.1 the first alpha and with this became
a new artifact called fragment testing
which is about like six years overdue
and it's really around being able to
test your Android X fragments in
isolation right separate from an
activity separate from everything else
but being able to test and verify that
that fragment is doing the right thing
we have unlockable layer right one of
the things that we found when building
navigation is that most companies once
they got to a certain point and they're
like wow we should add some testing and
they're like wow we can't really test
start activities so they built their own
navigator which just provides a layer to
mock out the start activity calls
well that that layer is handled for you
it's called nav controller we test nav
controller so now what we can do in our
activities is just mock out that nav
controller and
confirm that yes you're calling the
right navigate pulse you can't actually
do constructor injection into fragments
right you no longer need to only have a
no arcs constructor to use fragments you
can use a fragment factory to
instantiate your fragments for you we do
recommend using multiple activities not
a lot though so what I'd like to say is
you don't actually need multiply DVDs
what you need are multiple tasks
[Music]
I'd really like to end this with one
note a lot of you have existing apps
that have very different kind of
experiences and I'd like to say do
what's right for your app I think single
activity is great I was writing a new
activity it would also be single
activity but I realized that doing going
to your p.m. and be like hey let's rip
the whole app apart is sometimes a hard
sell some of them don't like your
current app so maybe you'll actually get
some yeah okay go for it
really depends on your own experience if
you find yourself contorting your own
experience and it's not making sense to
you don't do it right if something is
working that's good keep it working
right but if you're finding you're
running into issues you're having
inconsistent behavior right or you want
to do things like share view models
maybe that's the time to think about
moving towards a single activity
structure
[Music]